Kirby and it was taken in 1990 as he was
dying from age-related illness and it
was subsequently published in Life
Magazine the only real thing separating
me from Kirby is about 30 years of
medical advancements in the way that we
treat HIV and AIDS
so what I want to ask next is this if we
have made such exponential progress in
combating HIV why haven't our
perceptions of those with the virus
evolved alongside why does HIV elicit
this reaction from us when it's so
easily managed
when did the stigmatization even occur
and why hasn't it subsided and these are
not easy questions to answer
they're the congealing of so many
different factors and ideas powerful
images like this one of Kirby these were
the faces of the AIDS crisis in the 80s
and 90s and at the time the crisis had a
very obvious impact on an already
stigmatized group of people and that was
gay men so what the general straight
public saw was this very awful thing
happening to a group of people who were
already on the fringes of society the
media at the time began to use the two
almost interchangeably gay and AIDS and
at the 1984 Republican National
Convention one of the speaker's joked
that gays stood for
got AIDS yet and that was the mindset of
the time but as we started to understand
the virus more and how it was
transmitted we realized that that risk
had increased its territory the highly
profiled case of Ryan White in 1985 he
was a 13 year old haemophiliac who had
contracted HIV from a contaminated blood
treatment and this marked the most
profound shift in America's perception
of HIV no longer was it restricted to
these dark corners of society to queers
and drug users but now is affecting
people that society deemed worthy of
their empathy to children but that
permeating fear and that perception it
still lingers and I want to show of
hands for these next few questions how
many of you in here were aware that with
treatment those with HIV not only fend
off AIDS completely but they live full
and normal lives
Dola educated how many of you are aware
that with treatment those with HIV can
reach an undetectable status and that
makes them virtually uninfected and
post-exposure treatments that are
available that reduced the risk of
transmission by over 90 percent these
are incredible advancements that we have
made in fighting HIV yet they have not
managed to dent the perception that most
Americans have of the virus and those
living with it and I don't want you to
think I'm downplaying the danger of this
virus and I am not ignorant of the
harrowing past of the AIDS epidemic I am
trying to convey that there is hope for
those infected and HIV is not the death
sentence it was in the 80s and now you
may ask and I ask this question myself
initially where are the stories where
are these people living with HIV why
haven't they been vocal how can I
believe these successes are these
statistics without seeing the successes
and this is actually a very easy
question for me
answer fear stigma and shame these keep
those living with HIV in the closet so
to speak our sexual histories are as
personal to us as our medical histories
and when you overlap the two you can
find yourself in a very sensitive space
the fear of how others perceive us when
we're honest keeps us from doing many
things in life and this is the case for
the hiv-positive population to face
social scrutiny and ridicule is the
price that we pay for transparency and
why I become a martyr when you can
effectively pass as someone without HIV
after all there are no physical
indications you have the virus there's
no sign that you where there is safety
in assimilation and there is safety in
invisibility I'm here to throw back that
veil and share my story so in the fall
of 2014 I was a sophomore in college
and like most college students I was
sexually active and I generally took
precautions to minimize the risk that
sex carries now I say generally because
I wasn't always safe it only takes a
single misstep before we're flat on the
ground and my misstep is pretty obvious
I had unprotected sex and I didn't think
much of it fast forward about three
weeks and it felt like I'd been trampled
by a herd of wildebeest the aches in my
body were like nothing I have felt
before or since I'll get these bouts of
fever and chill I would real with nausea
and it was difficult to walk being a
biology student I had some prior
exposure to disease and being a fairly
informed gay man I had read a bit on HIV
so to me it clicked that this was
seroconversion or is it sometimes called
acute HIV infection and this is the
body's reaction in producing antibodies
to the HIV antigen it's important to
note that not everybody goes through
this phase of sickness but I was one of
the lucky ones who did and I was lucky
as then there were these physical
symptoms that let me know hey something
is wrong and it let me detect the virus
prettier
so just to clarify just to hit the nail
on the head I got tested on campus and
they called me or they said they would
call me the next morning with the
results and they called me
but they asked me to come in and speak
to the doctor on staff and the reaction
I received from her wasn't what I was
expecting
she reassured me of what I already knew
that this wasn't a death sentence and
she even offered to put me in contact
with her brother who had been living
with HIV since the early 90s I declined
her offer but I was deeply touched I was
expecting to be reprimanded I was
expecting pity and disappointment and I
was shown compassion and human warmth
and I'm forever grateful for that first
exchange so obviously for a few weeks I
was a physical mess emotionally mentally
I was doing okay I was taking it well
but my body was ravaged and those close
to me they weren't oblivious so I sat my
roommates down and I let them know I'd
been diagnosed with HIV that I was about
to receive treatment and I didn't want
them to worry and I remember the look on
their faces they were holding each other
on the couch and they were crying and I
consoled them I consoled them about my
own bad news but it was heartwarming to
see that they cared but from that night
I noticed a shift in the way that I was
treated at home my roommates wouldn't
touch anything of mine and they wouldn't
eat anything I had cooked now in South
Louisiana we all know that you don't
refuse food and I'm a damn good cook so
don't think that passed me by
but from these first silent hints there
their version got gradually more obvious
and more offensive I was asked to move
my toothbrush from the bathroom I was
asked to not share towels and I was even
asked to wash my clothes on a hotter
setting this wasn't headlights y'all
this wasn't scabies this was HIV it can
be transmitted through blood sexual
fluids like semen or vaginal fluids and
breast milk since I wasn't sleeping with
my roommates
I wasn't breastfeeding them and we
weren't reenacting Twilight I was of no
risk to them and and I made this aware
to them but still this discomfort it
continued until eventually I was asked
to move out and I was asked him about
because one of my roommates had shared
my status with her parents she shared my
personal medical information to
strangers and now I'm doing that in a
room full of 300 of y'all but at the
time this was not something I was
comfortable with and they expressed
their discomfort with their daughter
living with me so being gay raised in a
religious household and living in the
south discrimination wasn't new to me
but this form was and it was
tremendously disappointing because it
came from such an unlikely source not
only were these college-educated people
not only were they other members of the
LGBT community but they were also my
friends so I did I moved out at the end
of the semester but it wasn't to appease
them it was out of respect for myself I
wasn't going to subject myself to people
who were unwilling to remedy their
ignorant and I wasn't gonna let
something that was now a part of me ever
be used as a tool against me
so I opted for transparency about my
status always being visible and this is
what I like to call being the everyday
advocate the point of this transparency
the point of this everyday advocacy was
to dispel ignorant and ignorance is a
very scary word
we don't want to be seen as ignorant and
we definitely don't want to be called it
but ignorant is not synonymous with
stupid it's not the inability to learn
it's the state you're in
before you learn so when I saw someone
coming from a place of ignorance I saw
an opportunity for them to learn and
hopefully if I could spread some
education than I could mitigate
situations for others like I had
experience with my roommates and save
someone else down the line that
humiliation so the reactions I received
haven't been all positive here in the
South we have a lot of stigma due to
religious pressures our lack of a
comprehensive sex education and our
general conservative outlook on anything
sexual we view this as a gay disease
globally most new HIV infections occur
between heterosexual partners and here
in the states women especially women of
color are at an increased risk this is
not a gay disease it never has been it's
a disease we should all be concerned
with so initially I felt limited I
wanted to expand my scope and reach
beyond what was around me so naturally I
turned to the dark underworld of online
dating ads to apps like Grindr and for
those of you who are unfamiliar these
are dating apps targeted towards gay men
you can upload a profile in a picture
and it'll show you available guys within
a radius y'all have probably heard of
tinder grinder has been around for a lot
longer since it was much harder to meet
your future gay husband at church or the
grocery store or what whatever straight
people did before they found out they
could date on their phones so unkind ER
if you liked what you saw or read you
could send someone a message you can
meet up you can do other things so on my
profile I obviously stated that I had
HIV
I was undetectable and I welcomed
questions about my status and I received
a lot of questions and a lot of comments
both positive and negative and I want to
start with the negative just to frame
some of this ignorant
that I've mentioned before and most of
these negative comments were passing
remarks or assumptions they would assume
things about my sex life or my sex
habits they would assume I put myself or
others at risk but very often I would
just be met with these passing ignorant
remarks in the gay community it's common
to hear the word clean when you're
referring to someone who's HIV negative
of course the flip side to that is being
unclean or dirty when you do have HIV
now I'm not sensitive and I'm only truly
dirty after a day in the field but this
is damaging language this is a community
driven stigma that keeps mini gay men
from disclosing their status and it
keeps those newly diagnosed from seeking
support within their own community and I
find that truly distressing but
thankfully the positive responses have
been a lot more numerous and they came
from guys who were curious and they were
curious about the risks of transmission
or what exactly undetectable meant or
where they could get tested or some guys
would ask me about my experiences and I
could share my story with them but most
importantly I would get approached by
guys who were newly diagnosed with HIV
and they were scared
and they were alone and they didn't know
what step to take next they didn't want
to tell their family they didn't want to
tell their friends and they felt damaged
and they felt dirty and I did whatever I
could to immediately calm them and then
I would put them in contact with
Acadiana cares which is a wonderful
resource we have in our community for
those with HIV and I put them in contact
with people I knew personally so that
they could not only have this safe space
to feel human again
but so they could also have the
resources they needed in affording their
treatment and this was by far the most
humbling aspect of my transparency that
I could have some positive impact on
those those who are suffering like I did
that I could help those who were in the
dark because I had been there and it
wasn't a good place to be
these guys came from all different
backgrounds and many of them weren't as
informed as I had been and they were
coming to me
a place of fear some of these people I
knew personally are they knew of me but
many more they were anonymous there were
these blank profiles who were too afraid
to show their faces after what they had
told me and on the topic of transparency
I want to leave Yale with a few thoughts
I found that with whatever risk or
gamble I took in putting my face out
there it was well worth any negative
comment any flack I received because I
felt I was able to make this real and
this tangible impact and it showed me
that our efforts resound that we can
alter the lives that we encounter for
the good and they in turn can take that
momentum and push it even further and if
any of you or anyone you know is dealing
with HIV or if you want to see what
resources you have in your community or
just educate yourself more on the
disease here are some wonderful national
sites that you can access and you are
more than welcome to find me after this
talk and ask me anything you'd like
we've all heard the phrase to see the
forest through the trees so I'm for all
of you here to really see the human
through the disease it's a very easy
thing to see numbers and statistics and
only see the perceived dangers it's a
much harder thing to see all the faces
behind those numbers so when you find
yourself thinking those things as words
what you might have thought looking at
David Kirby I asked you instead think
son or think brother think front and
most importantly think human seek
education when faced with ignorance and
always be mindful and always be
compassionate thank you